- Hi, everyone, both here,
but many more of you who are online.
Welcome to another addition
of our conversation series sponsored
by the Yale Institute for Global Health.
I'm delighted to welcome
everyone to this event,
this hybrid event,
in addition to the Yale Institute
for Global Health or YIGH.
Today's event was sponsored
by the Walker Fund of the MacMillan Center.
The first cases of Covid 19 appeared
in Pakistan in February, 2020.
And as one of the most
densely populated countries
in the world actually serve,
several areas are very
densely populated in Pakistan.
It, the country,
was fairly vulnerable to adverse impacts
of this new pandemic.
And like any new pandemic,
like many countries in Asia,
particularly South Asia,
during today's event,
which is, as you know,
those are few who have been
following these events,
follows a series of conversations
over the last three years
on various global health related topics.
But one strand that has
run through a lot of these
conversations, certainly not
all of these conversations,
is the pandemic response,
starting with Dr. Anthony Fauci
in 2020, going through Dr. Tedros
from WHOs, the UNICEF directors,
four directors of CDC
and and so on and so forth,
and leaders from around the world.
So in this context,
we will discuss the challenges
of a pandemic response in Pakistan,
which is very interesting in the sense
that it has a federally
devolved health system,
but there are several functions
that are centralized as well.
And there is a specific need in a pandemic
to make real time data driven decisions.
We will outline how these
challenges were overcome,
including lessons for around the world
on how to respond to future pandemics.
Unfortunately, this is not
the last infectious disease related event
that we'll be seeing.
And one misnomer is that
it's 100 year pandemic,
but 100 year, looking back,
looking ahead, it will is likely to be,
there is evidence that it is
likely to be more frequent.
With that in mind, I'm very,
very pleased to introduce
our honored guests,
Dr. Faisal Sultan, who's
the former special assistant
to the Prime Ministers on a prime minister
of Pakistan on national health services
regulation and coordination.
Or in short,
he had the portfolio
of the Federal Minister
of Health in Pakistan.
Dr. Sultan is an infectious
disease physician
and has been the CEO of the
largest cancer hospital,
in fact, the largest
cancer hospital network
in a large country like
Pakistan for several years.
And you know, in addition
to more recently serving
in his government
capacity, he's a graduate
of the King Edward
Medical College in Lahar,
but did his residency here
in Connecticut at UConn
and had, if I can say so,
a formative rotation at
Yale where he was inspired
to do infectious diseases
and some of his mentors
are still at Yale, and
credits are inspiration,
this institution's inspiration
to change the trajectory of his career.
He also trained in infectious diseases
at Washington University
School of Medicine.
He serves on several high level national
and international for including
Pakistan Science Foundation,
Pakistan Medical Research Council,
and the HPV Human Paola
Virus Advisory Committee
for the World Health or Organization.
He also served on the
board of a Global Alliance
for Vaccine and Immunization,
or Gavi, the Vaccine Alliance.
Welcome, Dr. Sultan.
- Thank you.
- So first we'll start
with a broad question.
How did Pakistan do in
responding to Covid 19
how was Pakistan's response
somewhat similar to,
and what were some of the
differentiating features compared
to other lower and middle income countries
in Sub-Saharan Africa,
in South Asia and
Southeast Asia more broadly
and in the Middle East?
- Great.
So I think,
some of it is subjective obviously.
I think generally we were able to do well,
but there were a number
of measures or metrics
that one could think about
or talk about that would make one think
that we came out of it somewhat okay
or better than some other countries.
I think very broadly,
one could look at things like mortality,
things like overload of
the healthcare system
or how far and how fast
the economy recovered
post Covid or during it.
And so I think a number of
these measures point out
towards somewhat, I
wouldn't say easier time,
but a better outcome
than some other countries
that went through.
Comparisons are odious
and it is very difficult to make across,
especially across countries
with difficult different systems
and political structures.
But for similar size countries
with similar challenges,
I think I would say that
many other large federal
structure countries
did suffer quite a lot
and relative to them,
I think we came out a little bit ahead.
- So in terms of, yes,
so you right that in
terms of data collected
by our Walden data and others,
there were mortality sort
of metrics that were lower, et cetera,
and sort of independent
data validation has shown
that if you can triangulate
those data, et cetera,
obviously there are data
issues and any pandemic.
But broadly speaking,
sort of they have been,
some of those features there.
In terms of, take us behind the scenes
because one of the lessons this pandemic
has taught us that it's not necessarily
the technology, it's the operations,
how the public health response is managed.
Take us behind the scenes,
what were the leadership lessons
as a public health theater you learned
in responding to the pandemic?
- I think some of the
most important lessons,
or if I could call them
leadership lessons or you know,
on lessons in general as
well that came out of this,
and they certainly relate to some
of behind the scenes efforts
that were made relate to
the fact that coherence
and data driven decision making,
and that too in such a way
that is well communicated, well received,
and then the ability to follow
through on many of those
recommendations and,
mandates or guidelines or restrictions
that we all came about with.
So the ability to do this
in a coherent data driven,
consistent and flexible
way was the key lesson
that came out of this.
When we started out, I
think within Pakistan,
as in across the globe,
there was confusion as
to how to deal with it.
People had seen what had happened,
say for example, in China and Wuhan
where they had the ability to shut down,
an area or a city or a province,
and yet continue to function as a country.
Then we all saw images
and news and numbers coming out of some
of the first European countries
and then Iran next to us,
that that suffered
heavily through mortality
and how the disease spread
and how it pressured
the healthcare system.
So this, there was indeed confusion
and a whole range of diversity of opinion
on how you could deal with it.
On one hand, there were people
who were the naysayers who felt that this
was all, some, a problem that
didn't exist, the nalist.
And then on the other hand,
there were people who wanted very early
and very harsh and very blunt measures,
which would be very destructive
for the country as a whole.
And so you had to find
not just a middle path
or an equal equidistant middle part,
but a but a response that one
would tackle the pandemic,
but would also allow life to go on.
So, this sweet spot
did not necessarily have to be
right at smack in the center,
but it had to be data driven and driven
by the science of it.
And it was finding this by
creating data flow networks,
creation of expertise, sort of pools,
the ability to analyze some of this,
the ability to scale up,
whether it was oxygen or PPEs or beds
or the raw supply of oxygen to predict
where the next, outbreaks would be.
And then to, of course ensure
that vaccination happened.
So all of this was a complex
dance that that had to be done.
And I think the most important
lesson out of this is that we
may be a federal and many other countries
may be federally devolved
diverse countries,
but for a pandemic response,
we must have the ability for
a cohesive central response.
- So a little bit more
operational details.
- Yeah.
- So I think this was a really good sort
of overview in terms of,
tell us a little bit about the,
your emergency operations center,
which was called the NCOC,
the national something.
- Right?
- Coordination.
How did you get the data
in a sort of, in a country,
how do you use geographic systems where,
and a little bit about,
specific supply chains,
issues like oxygens, et cetera,
that how you estimated that need
and how did you respond
to that in real time.
- Right?
- Which is, as I recall,
Pakistan had strains on
this oxygen supply chain,
but it never had real shortages
and that kind of a cycle
when there are shortages and
then people sort of keep it
for their families and their hospitals,
et cetera and that kind of stuff.
So how were you able to avoid that?
- Right.
So let's begin at one end.
So the first of all was
the governance end of it,
and the NCOC got formed really as well.
- What does that stand for?
- The National Corona Operations Center?
- [Saad] Yeah.
- And so, the command
and operations center
for Corona came into being
when the National Security Council figured
that it really was a
threat to national security
and for the government to be able to have
a whole of the government approach,
which connected all
the federating entities
had expertise marshaled
in, had a civilian head
of the response, but have a military arm
to help them with a lot of
the follow up procedures
that were required and to be able
to connect to not just the provinces,
but elements and entities
within the federal government.
So that was the governance
piece that got fixed
with the formation of the NCOC.
The cadence was met every
day for hours at a time,
and it was all data-centric
talking about data.
So one of the most important
bits to be done was to create
a realtime flow of data, for example,
testing, for example, fill of beds,
the number of oxygen beds,
the PPEs is required.
So all this required that
we had efficient data flows
and databases that talk
that talked in real time.
So we connected all the
nearly 200 labs, 173,
I think was the max
that were, for example,
testing for PCR for coronavirus,
and to connect them either directly
or through the provincial dashboards.
And so we were able to
piggyback onto what existed
as the IDIMS, which was
the polio dashboard,
added a few fields to it in real time.
And so the data flow started
to become real time and accurate.
Then of course,
the other important thing
was we needed to know
where space was or where you
had actually spare capacity,
because we realized that the epidemic
would not be even,
you will have surges in one place
and relative spare capacity,
perhaps in the same town
without being aware of it.
So this visibility of
the resource required
a resource management system.
So over 3000 healthcare institutions
were connected to it in real time,
gaining a number, how many people were,
how many beds were available,
how many oxygen beds,
how many vent beds, and so on.
And similarly,
an infrastructure for
the information system
for vaccines had to be created.
All of this got helped tremendously,
and I have to tell you this,
because all Pakistani citizens
have a national digital identity.
All of us have a number,
and so all tests that were done
were tagged to a national number.
All the vaccines that were
given were tagged to a number.
And so this, the ability to
capture this data was important.
The other layers that were added
that really helped us
was a geographic layer.
So if we knew where somebody was
and based on census data,
we could tell where there were hotspots
in complete real time.
And therefore that
helped us to have nuanced
and targeted those
so-called smart lockdown
instead of shutting down the entire city.
So in a sort of quick breathless,
we have told you how to,
how we were able to
utilize some of the data
and technologies that existed.
We used geolocation,
we also used how people's
geographic address matched up.
And not only that was that
used for contact tracing,
but, and for hotspot detection,
but also how we scheduled
people for vaccinations.
So we would schedule
you close to your house
or your address to a
center that was near you,
and of course, we went down by age.
So all this was held by
having that information
at a central place.
- So, elaborate a little bit more
on the so-called smart lockdown,
especially in early phases of it.
How was that different from,
the blanket lockdowns, et cetera,
and what enabled you to do those kinds
of prevention measures?
Obviously later in the pandemic,
you didn't do that,
especially after the back
scene became available,
but in the relatively early phases,
how did you switch to that strategy and-
- Right, so the first lockdown
was it wasn't terribly smart
on a number of occasions.
It wasn't smart in the sense
that it was not targeted.
Entire provinces got shut down,
or large cities within
provinces got shut down.
This happened on the 23rd
of the 24th of March, 2020,
and happened more as a
cascade of shutdowns.
And I was reminded almost,
you that that famous line as
the first World War breakout
and looking out the
prime minister's window,
I think it was a treasury secretary
who said in the UK that,
the lights out are going
out all over Europe
and they might not see it
lit over their lifetime.
And that was almost the
feeling some of us got that,
almost a cascade of
shutdowns were happening,
and we really did not know how
and when we would be able
to walk out of those.
But that was more a reactive phenomenon.
Once that happened, we
got to work and said,
"Look, in a country of
220 million people spread
over 1000s of miles,
we cannot be having this blunt approach."
And we were able to figure out
the presence of the disease
because it was tagged.
All those 200 labs,
or nearly 200 labs that were contributing,
were mandated to actually capture
the computerized national identity number.
And therefore we knew by
geography as to approximately
what areas were hotspots.
But not only that,
we also had geolocation information
because in addition to the number,
we were also capturing
the cell phone number.
So we could tell approximately
in an anonymized fashion
where the hotspots were.
And then for contact tracing,
obviously the contact tracing teams
in all the four provinces in the six
or seven federating units had the ability
to do contact tracing based on
that geolocated information.
So once we got through
one or two cycles of this,
we realized that we could use heat maps
for the entire country.
And those heat maps were then communicated
out to the provincial entities
who then could act on it in
a very sort of smart way.
So the lockdowns became very tight,
few neighborhoods, few streets even,
and without shutting down the entire city
and paralyzing life.
So I think, and this
continue almost till the end,
each time there was a surge,
we were able to say, "Okay,
fine, this is where the surge is."
And within the city,
this is where the worst
part of the surge is,
and whether it had direct mobility impacts
or it actually altered behavior
through messaging is unclear.
Obviously hard to ascribe
in sort of in a dynamic way,
but I think all of these
things had an effect.
- Good.
So look, you are a physician,
physician executive, physician scientist,
but you know, in a pandemic by necessity
a whole of government response is needed
and the whole of government
is headed by politicians.
So any lessons, in this private sanctum,
(laughs) well, no, we are being recorded,
but any lessons about
dealing with politicians
and in Pakistan,
to said the context has
provincial governments
from different parties.
There was a sort of a prime minister
is a prime minister, there's,
it's a different person in charge now.
And so how did you deal with that
and what are some of the dynamics
that are illustrative of that interaction?
- So just to test out the whole thing
and to test everyone's nerves
and ability to work with everyone else,
there was a full rainbow of colors
as far as the parties were concerned.
So almost each province had
a different government
from a different party.
And so that was one of
the initial difficulties,
people singing slightly different tunes.
And by design saw, this is
the other bit by design,
a federal government is more worried
about the overall economic impact,
whereas provincial or
local estate governments
are more worried on the
impact at a more local level.
So by design, almost by
default, their angle of direct,
I mean angle of view
is slightly different.
They have different perspectives.
So to merge and bring everybody
to the same place
required the usual things,
conversations reach out professional
to professional
peer-to-peer conversations.
So some of us in the NCOC
were able to reach out
to our professional colleagues
that were advising the same government
or the KK government, and were they there,
at least it was the same PTI government
and to other colleagues
across the country.
So one of one was this conversation,
this reach out,
this cobbling together
of opinion and views.
That was one.
The other bit of course was that the NCOC
was headed by Mr. Asad Omar.
Asad was a fantastic
colleague to work with.
He was the planning minister,
had worked in the private
sector for a major food company
and had been been politics for 10 years.
And so he understood
both sides of the divide.
And I think he was able to have
the centrality and the
coherence of this discussion.
He had private, relationships
and knowledge of all the politicians
and the political entities that existed
in the federal entity as
well as in the provinces.
So it was difficult.
I personally had an
easier time in that sense
that I had tremendous trust
with the prime minister
having worked for his
hospital for 25 years.
So that was a peculiar advantage that not,
so that's not so easily
reproducible for everyone,
but I think that was a personal advantage
that I had the trust
of the chief executive.
But I think overall, regardless of that,
you have to cobble together
these conversations,
these unions and a trust network
that eventually got
built in was very robust.
- So just switching to your other role,
which I would say your
day job I do, which is a,
the physician and a physician leader
at a major sort of network
of cancer hospital,
which is the shock Athan
Memorial Cancer hospital
and the sort of, and the research center
describe your experience running
and almost setting up a
major tertiary care entity.
Rightfully there's been a lot of focus
of global health on
primary care, et cetera.
And obviously no country or region
can have a claim to a robust health system
without a robust primary care system.
But obviously, things like cancer happen.
- Yeah.
- And they require major investment
in tertiary care hospital hospitals.
So, set the stage for our colleagues here,
what was the situation of cancer care
before the entity was established?
What are some of your lessons from,
helping establish that and expanding
that hospital and now the,
a network of hospitals?
- So Mercy Olivo,
these two years that I
was in the government,
I was on sabbatical from here,
so I wasn't wearing both hats or else
I would've gone completely
off the deep end.
But, so my, I started working at Johanna
as soon as I moved back from
the us this would be 1995.
And my initial role was that
as an infectious diseases physician,
and I waited myself into our,
I think life and luck
and happenstance took me
to the chief executives position off note.
I actually had no formal managerial
or administrative experience or background
or formal education background.
So it was a bit of a chance
that the board took on me
and a bit of a chance I
myself took on myself.
So I think through this time what I would,
if I could summarize this,
I think the most important thing
that I have seen through
shohan is the fact that
the board had very
complete clarity of mission
that hasn't wavered, there
hasn't been mission creep,
they haven't confused themselves
into what they're all about.
It is about cancer and it is about having
a tertiary care organization.
And it is about making sure
that there is access to the poor.
That the fundamental pivot
on which the hospital was made
was the fact that you
needed to provide access
to those that cannot afford it.
And so all through the hospital
has remained true to that mission.
Things that I've learned along the way,
a lot of it I ended up using,
and I think they came in extremely handy
during my time in government.
Were were things about, again,
about collaboration, about humility,
about understanding that your responses
and your plans change
about being data driven,
about having very important information
and technology backbones at Shaka Harum,
we've had an electronic health record,
a fully automated
electronic health records.
It's 2005 and a homegrown one at that.
So all of these things
require the ability to work
with people and work
with all sorts of people.
And I think tho were some of the,
key leadership lessons that I was able
to learn and continue to learn even today
where the mission and focus
of the hospital remains that person,
that child or that adult who is otherwise
not able to access quality cancer care
and to provide them with a top class
place where there is absolute
even handling of their care,
it does not matter.
We really do not care if you are paying
or you're not paying as far as
the institution is concerned,
everybody's handled the same way.
Some, of those lessons
also came in very handy
when we actually rolled
out there the vaccine
in Pakistan and making
sure that it was completely
fair across the board.
- So interesting.
So we will go into the phase
where we will take questions.
- Sure.
- From our online and in-person attendees.
We'll start this time.
We often start with in-person audiences,
we will start with online folks.
We already have a few questions,
but others are welcome,
who are sort of here in person
to come up with your questions, et cetera.
So, there were two related questions.
One was, obviously it's a large country
you were dealing with provincial
governments, et cetera,
but there are large cities
like Karachi, like Lahar,
and you know, all sorts of municipalities,
even smaller ones are
pretty large compared to-
- Sure.
- Because it's a large and
dense densely populated country.
So how did you interact with them or the,
that was a sort of a two
degrees removed interaction.
Did you directly interact with them?
And the second thing was the
other end of the spectrum,
and it's interesting that
both of these questions came
together was how did you reach out?
So while there is there highly
dense populated area areas,
there's a long tail of sparsely populated,
hard to reach locations,
and there are major equity concerns-
- Absolutely.
- In, this kind of a pandemic.
So how did you address these
two ends of the spectrum?
- Great question.
So first of all,
as far as the structure of
government is concerned,
as far as the official
position is concerned,
we could only act through
the provincial governments.
So the NCC and the NCOC had
provincial representation.
- And what does NCO, NCC-
- So the NCC was the governance entity
that was the national Corona committee,
which actually was chaired
by the prime minister.
- Yeah.
- And had the chief
ministers as part of it.
And the membership from
the NCOC sat on it as well.
So that was the upper governance committee
and the operational bit was the NCOC,
which met on a daily basis.
And so it was structured that way.
So we had two and we legally have to go
through the chief ministers
or the representatives,
but our reach out there
was focused on individual
or larger cities or cities
with larger problems
or current problems at that time.
So for example, in many of the waves,
the timing of the two waves
or the waves were different.
So for example, in some of,
in some waves it was Karara
that was first and Lahar later
and the other way around.
So our ability to reach out
to these individual cities
were through the district administrations,
but we always worked through
the chief secretaries
of the provinces.
So the, in our structure,
the chief secretary is
the senior most bureaucrat
that reports to the chief
minister of the province.
And so we always reached out to them,
but to be perfectly honest, we would also,
by keeping them in the
loop in the copy list,
we could reach out through
the NCC to individual district
commissioners or to the
commissioners of the cities directly
as well where there was,
- So the commissioner is
the city level (indistinct).
- Is city or area or
zone level, bureau level,
highest bureaucrat and so on.
We also had to of course,
by default engage all the
relevant line ministries.
So if you were going to
talk about, say, convincing,
the mosques to obtain,
to create some distance between,
how people prayed during
reanne, for example,
you had to engage through the
Ministry of Religious Affairs.
So, the whole of the government,
that was the beauty of the place,
the convening power and reach
of the NCOC was massive.
So you could get anybody in the room real
or virtual and reach out.
And that included the private sector
when it came to making sure
that we had enough oxygen,
we were able, within the
first wave of the pandemic,
we were able to raise
our oxygen production,
the raw oxygen production,
66% by just unlocking a few roadblocks
that existed on some plants
that were either dysfunctional
or did not have one supply or the other.
And to sort those out.
So it was vertically,
down to the provinces or
the cities and districts,
but also horizontally within
the federal government.
- So it's an interesting question,
but before that is there any question
from the in-person audience?
Yes, go ahead.
We'll take one from here.
- [Audient] Yeah, sure.
So my question is,
you talked about the difference
between being reactive versus proactive.
Just looking ahead in time.
So I know that there was a
big problem in the procurement
and distribution of the vaccine,
especially during the onset.
Was there an effort in Pakistan
to create its own vaccine
and was it, if yes, was it successful?
Because I believe until this point
there's no local vaccine there.
- Right?
So the engagement with the
potential vaccine suppliers
started in the summer of 2020
and we actually created a vaccine
experts advisory group
that took a survey, a view,
a landscape view of the
entire likely chances
of what was going to reach the pipeline.
And despite this, as was expected,
as almost all of us could predict
that when actually the
vaccines came on board,
they would be a clear supply issue.
And those countries that
actually had inherent
or native supplies would end
up supplying themselves first.
This, nationalism or vaccine nationalism
is almost predicted.
So yes, we had initial difficulties
in jump starting the supply.
We got some donations from China
and some old strategic
partnerships worked out there
and that was donation.
But the hiccup came when
Gavi that had been hoping
and leveraging on supply
from India, for example,
for the AstraZeneca vaccine,
that that supply got
disrupted because India
had its own way and predictively
and understandably they had
to serve their own population.
And so our initial supply,
which we thought would come from Gavi,
the whole thing had to be turned around.
We thought that initially
we'd be able to deploy
through Gavi and buy later.
And whereas it got turned
the other way around,
we had to buy initially and
then Gavi followed up later.
In terms of domestic supply,
the one success we did have
was fill in formulation
of a single dose Chinese vaccine can sign.
But beyond that, we do not have,
at this time a national supply
of an indigenously made vaccine,
whether developed locally
or whether manufacturer
of an externally developed vaccine.
This is a key gap that needs to be filled.
- [Saad] Yeah.
So let's take.
- [Audient] Thank you so much
for coming to speak with us.
So my question was on this note
of indigenously sourced vaccines,
we saw with polio virus in Pakistan prior,
that there was an issue about
the source of the vaccine
and how it came from the west.
So I'm interested to
hear your perspectives
on how information was
disseminated regarding
the vaccine and sort of
how vaccine hesitancy
was perhaps addressed through NCC.
- Right, so this is an off ask question,
and I'll tell you that
while one can never swear
that there was no vaccine hesitancy
that be a silly position to take.
But if I could venture to
say that relatively speaking,
we had very little vaccine hesitancy
or hard resit vaccine hesitancy
as far as the Covid vaccine was concerned.
In fact, I would argue that
when we did surveys
as well as when the
practical rollout happened,
there wasn't any hesitancy.
There may have been laziness
and in certain circumstances
where the vaccine was available
and people required to
be reminded or you know,
reminded of not only the
availability but near availability
and then flipping the thing around
and taking the vaccine to them
instead of asking them to
come to the vaccine center.
So of the thousands and thousands
of vaccine centers that were created,
eventually we realized no, we're gonna,
we need to go to them.
So the mo mobile vaccination teams
were created to make sure
that there was ease of access
as far as the part in
the brain is concerned,
which is to convince them,
the mental part of it.
I don't think we had too
much of a difficult time
in making that happen.
By and large,
there was acceptance of the fact that
a vaccine was required.
We did use many levers available to us.
For example, we are a young country,
25% of the 25 a fourth of
the country goes to schools,
colleges, universities, et cetera.
So he said, look,
all faculty and staff at all
educational institutions need
to be fully vaccinated.
And so that was sort of an
obligation that was put on.
Then of course they could opt out
through for medical reasons
cetera, but by and large,
and the uptake was in the high 90s.
Similarly for a number of
other things, transportation.
So for airlines,
pretty soon there was a time
when you could not fly
without a vaccine certificate.
Restaurants in the hospitality industry
was really encouraged very strongly,
if I could use that word,
to make sure that all their
patrons were indeed vaccinated.
So all these levers were used,
but we never had hard resistance
to vaccine acceptance.
And it wasn't national in the,
how shall I put it,
the vaccine acceptance
or preference, if I will,
was not based on national vaccine
or source of the vaccine at all.
The public formed its own views.
What they wanted,
and we could see this on vaccine centers.
So we are one country that
were offering seven vaccines
at one point, and more
or less it was up to you,
you could really go get what you wanted
and to keep the entire system flowing.
Imagine a country 220 million people
and the entire vaccine network flush
and flowing with all
the vaccines available,
especially when some doses were.
So the Sputnik, for example,
had dose one and those
two that were different.
So you had to make sure
that if you had X number
of potential vaccines that had
gotten dose, one of Sputnik,
that the second dose, which
was obviously different,
used a different virus
vector, was also available.
And despite that, we,
I don't think that that
was the major challenge.
Our challenge initially
was the initial supply
as was asked, well,
once the whole thing got flowing,
that wasn't an issue.
- So yeah, there's another one.
And then go online.
- [Audient] Thank you.
- Yeah.
- [Audient] So in thinking
about the national
like digital ID number you mentioned
it's very exciting
'cause I know we have a lot of struggles
around that in the US.
What were some of the challenges faced
in kind of reaching those margin,
like those in marginalized community
who might not be counted in that,
and what are some of the cost and benefits
of the ID numbers in that context?
- So the digital ID, as you perhaps know,
predates all of this.
The first attempts of this
were from the 70s, mid 70s.
So almost all of us have had a number.
And then that eventually got transformed
into the computerized
number two decades ago.
So we've all had one way or the other,
a national digital identity.
The estimates from the organization
that manages this data is that about four
to five percent of people don't have it.
They are either those
that are below the radar,
haven't bothered to get it or whatever,
whatever sets of reason
they're marginalized
or disadvantaged in some way
or have never felt the need.
Perhaps one was to encourage
that those that are Pakistani citizens
and can easily get that to say, well look,
here's an opportunity.
We even worked with naro,
that's the entity that runs
this to create mobile teams
to go and actually register people.
Here's an opportunity,
here's a vaccine, please get
yourself registered and so on.
So creating that ease.
But then there are populations
that are actually not Pakistani at all.
So the largest of those were Afghans
and they have very often an Afghan card.
And so that was added as to
the list of eligibilities
where you could actually go and
show that and get that done.
Beyond that, there were other,
situations where they were
truly undocumented people.
And so the vaccine database,
the NIMS as we call it,
had provisions created in effort
to enable vaccine centers
to create a record
and actually give them the vaccine.
We did not do this initially primarily
because for a massive deployment
of 200 something million people
to ensure there was documented,
there was no bill fridge theft
or substitution, et cetera,
that we remained somewhat true
and there was fidelity to
the CNIC, the national ID.
But as we went along, we realized that,
we are not gonna get out
of it without making sure
that it was truly equitable
and reached all the
marginalized parts of society.
So yes, it, had mechanisms
built to allow people
without a digital identity
and we were happy with
working on the edges
of a little bit of, I
wouldn't say regularity,
but lack of accuracy.
You can't be 100% accurate
in such a large deployment.
So we built that
acceptance mechanism in it.
- So I have a question
from Dr. Stan Verman
who is online.
So Dr. Verman just,
recently stepped down as the dean
of the School of public Health,
and he has a long history
of working in Pakistan
and training who are
now leaders in Pakistan,
in the academia and
the government as well,
through especially the syn government,
but also at the federal level,
folks who went through several
of his training programs over the years.
So he sort of has a question around that.
They, in recent years,
the pashtoon population in
the Haber platoon province
and what was formerly
the federally administer
tribal areas now sort of,
they are called settled areas.
- Yeah.
- Et cetera.
And, even sort of in karate,
it's in the south as well.
The population has a
recent history of hesitancy
and refusal around polio vaccine.
So while there may not be much
of a hesitancy at the national level,
but did you have a communication
strategy to preempt
or respond to communities
that have refused other vaccines?
- So I met Dr. Wilman just
two days ago at ID week,
and we had a brief conversation.
So I know him very well by reputation,
I have met him before as well.
The short answer is that we did not find
the kind of hesitation or refusal
that we find with polio
with this vaccine at all.
And it was not regional
in that way as well.
So in other words,
the reach out of these
vaccination teams was easier
and for some reason,
and I can conjecture as to perhaps
what those reasons are.
It had an easier sell or it
has an easier acceptance.
We also tried to have a
mutually beneficial relationship
between two vaccines.
So during the polio campaigns per force,
because the same vaccination
forces out there,
we had to pause or slow down
some of the Covid vaccine,
but then we were very conscious
of the fact that other waves were coming.
It was very important to get
as much of the population
covered while there was
acceptance and before fatigue,
or indifference built in.
So we would create a
situation where people
would go get the polio
vaccine, but also we would,
they would have nearby
mobile vaccination teams
for the Covid vaccine
so that if there was
acceptance we could do it.
So in other, we tried to
help both of the campaigns
by synergy with each other.
Fortunately we were
fortunate that the heads
of the EPI, the expanded
program for immunization
as well as the head for the polio program,
had great working chemistry,
both became good friends with me
and one actually I'd known from earlier.
So that that personal chemistry
and trust also helped in
synchronizing these campaigns.
I have to tell you that for
the measles vaccine though,
we actually had to hard
stop the Covid vaccine
because the rate of adverse reaction
for Covid for measles vaccines are higher.
And therefore the experts
that looked at it said,
"Well look,
you're likely to damage the credibility
of your Covid vaccination program
because of the expected or
the estimated adverse effects
that are gonna come from
the measles vaccine."
We did 90 million kids during that time,
so that was also a huge campaign.
So for those 12 days we had to pause
the Covid vaccination.
So we really did not have
that kind of regional
or ethnic based resistance to this vaccine
as we have seen with polio.
- So another question is, by the way,
I'm looking at my phone
not because I'm sort of texting
my friends is because
that's where the questions
are coming from or online questions.
So they haven't sort of had
developed the technology
to directly transmitted
it to my brain ship.
So, there's another follow up question on,
since you mentioned polio,
what is the situation?
So Pakistan had made
progress around eliminating
and near eradicating polio,
but we know that new cases are there.
What is the latest situation?
I know that you have stepped away
from your government position,
but obviously, so you,
the situation there.
- Yeah, so I have to
answer this one carefully.
I have less restraint and a
non-governmental position today,
but this one I have to answer carefully
because of the intense polarization
of political perceptions, et cetera,
within our country.
Anyway.
So for a full straight year
and more we had zero polio cases,
and not only that polio
was at low numbers,
but our environmental sampling also,
and we were, we talked about
environmental sampling,
environmental sampling also suggested
that we were actually making good headway.
We were worried, however,
from good data that we knew
that there were reservoirs
and those were particular areas.
And those had to do with
some of the same populations
that Dr. Berman was talking about,
especially mobile populations
as well as from certain ethnic groups
that have a certain amount
of mistrust and distrust.
I think what has fundamentally
happened in those places
is that the quality of
campaigns and one can't,
say it anymore delicately than this,
that the quality of campaigns
leaves something to be desired.
Now there is a slider
that you have to move
to reach into hard to reach populations.
It is crucially important to have people
from within those communities
or else your campaign
is not gonna succeed.
But when they are within from
within those communities,
your ingress into the stringency,
the fidelity of those campaigns is not
as high as it would be had
it been normal employees
that you hire in.
And so therefore the
chances of fake marking
or of you know, of
being worried that okay,
if they report non
walks vaccine acceptance
and the next day the,
because this is the way it is,
the next day the deputy
commissioner is sitting standing
outside the house and saying, "Well,
why are you not getting vaccine?"
So, to prevent such social.
- [Saad] And sorry to interrupt.
So the deputy commissioner
is also a senior level.
- Senior level.
- [Saad] Bureaucrat.
- Bureaucrat who there.
(indistinct)
So because it is such an important topic,
the government has raised
the heat on this matter,
and so therefore the
intense governmental focus
on that zone or household or neighborhood
would mean that that neighborhood
might feel that they
have been squealed upon
by, that last vaccinator
who they refused to.
And so the,
so socialization, ostracization
or worse that could happen
sometimes creates these situations
where people will either mark fakely
or will just report that
they've, vaccinated.
So it is the quality of campaigns,
which is sometimes poor in these hard
to vaccinate areas where
the trouble arises,
it has solutions but requires diligence
and continued pressure.
I'm pretty sure it'll happen.
- Yeah.
Do you have a question?
- [Audient] No, No.
- Okay.
So there was a question
at the back that I saw.
So yeah, this one and then, yeah.
- [Audient] Thank you.
Thank you so much for coming.
I wanted to ask a question
more from a policy perspective.
In the tri-state area,
in many regions globally,
the fallout from Covid
resulted in a backlog
and essentially a complete moratorium
on a lot of routine screenings
such as breast cancer screenings,
it's breast cancer awareness
month around the world.
And during Covid, a lot of people
were not able to tackle their disease
at the earliest, especially
in the United States.
And it had a lot of health
equity implications.
I'm very curious to know how
this was managed in Pakistan
and what was the impact
in cancer hospitals
where people needed routine
screenings or biopsies
and surgeries, not just
for the late stage cancers,
but for early stage diagnoses.
Because in the United States,
an approach that was taken
resulted in early stage
just being tabled entirely,
which for people who are diagnosed
early is their best opportunity
to tackle a disease.
So I'm very curious to know
about the Covid fallout.
Thank you.
- So if I may add sort of another question
to a supplemental question to that.
So you are seeing,
the tertiary care facility.
Are you seeing any data trends that people
are now presenting at
a more advanced stage
of cancer, et cetera, related to that?
- Okay, so there are two
parts of this question.
One the more policy part and
the other is the more sort of
the impact of that policy.
If it were,
I'll tell you that one of
the most important arguments
that I could use personally at the time
against broad blunt and
blunt is what I should say,
lockdowns was exactly this.
That on one hand we do want to save lives,
forget the economic argument for a second.
You want to save lives,
but the disruption to preventive systems
to help promotive systems,
early detection and just routine care.
A woman that's that may
require to have a c-section
and she ends up delaying it because,
there isn't adequate care available.
You know, even mundane stuff like this was
this was the argument as far
as people like myself made
and the prime minister as well,
the ex prime minister,
Mr. Han(indistinct),
that we cannot do it at an either or.
We have got to try to
find a path that allows us
to slow down things where
it's required absolutely,
but to continue the rest of life,
whether healthcare or
other things renovated.
So overall it did have an impact.
So when you have in the initial shutdown
that the so-called lockdown,
the first one there were,
and we had data that some
catch up, immunizations,
et cetera, had to be done or given.
There were also some reductions
in the pickup of tuberculosis
cases, for example,
in our context that you expected to see
and they were not there
and then they did eventually come through.
So the policy was to ensure
that we could continue
things as much as possible.
And I just gave you the
other example about measles.
Here we were, the NCOC said,
"Well look guys, Dr. Fessel Sultan,"
you may be the health minister
and you have other fish to fry,
but we are the NCOC we
are worried about covid.
And I would say, well look,
you are wearing one hat,
I've got the other one
and I cannot let measles
go through or polio go through.
So all those campaigns had to be juggled.
So all these balls had to
be juggled at the same time.
So as far as policy was concerned,
the governmental was policy was concerned,
it was to try as much as
possible to not heart services.
However, as you correctly mentioned,
because many hospitals reduce services
and what ends up got gets thrown
out is stuff that can wait
and usually that is
earlier or milder disease
of one sort or the other.
So it did have impact
for our own hospital,
I have to tell you because I was away,
I wasn't part of that
decision in my place,
but we did not shut down services,
we continued services
and so we did not have
backlogs of that kind,
Various mitigation strategies
were used including remote clinics
that the whole world, employed.
But at least for Hanham
there was not a major.
- So you're not seeing any more severe
like sort of cases at presentation?
- We are not.
- Okay.
So there was a question at the back
and then we'll come to online questions
and then we'll come back
to in person questions.
- [Audience] Hi.
So my question is kind of similar category
that previous questions have been.
What was the impact of
pandemic on childhood routine
immunization in Pakistan
and how is Pakistan dealing?
First, are there any numbers to reflect
on what is the magnitude of that setback
and what are the strategies
that Pakistan is using right
now to mitigate that setback?
- So yes, as far as
through the first shutdown,
which was from the 23rd
of, or 24th of March,
2020 for about three weeks,
there was a drop in for that time period,
but it was transient and
it was all caught up.
In fact, if anything,
the routine immunization coverage across
the country has gone up the delta
for over a three or four year timeframe.
This is by third parties,
not by the government is 10%.
So actually a lot of people
are pleasantly surprised
that despite Covid,
the routine immunization
numbers have actually gone up.
I think some of the synergies,
and this is interesting,
some of the can do when
approach or a winner approach
that has happened because of Covid
has really energized some
of our vaccine programs.
I do think that after Covid where,
good 90% of the eligible population
as of mid-September had at
least two doses of vaccine.
So for a country like Pakistan
where people expected that
this is going to take years,
it has actually leapfrogged,
many more developed countries.
So I think that it will synergize
and help the RI program,
the routine immunization program.
But obviously I'm not
in government right now,
so I can't give you the official figures,
but I do think that the dent was there,
but it was temporary.
- So yeah,
so Gavi and UNICEF and actually UNICEF
and WHO estimated in Pakistan
was one of the countries
that did not see a major
backslide at a year by year basis.
Obviously there was that
backslide those four weeks.
- Those for (indistinct).
- In that period, et cetera.
But the concern a lot of us have is that,
there are second, third order
effects of major disruptions.
Do you think that kind of,
because there's fatigue in
health workers, there's,
the system even if it,
it delivered during the immediate phase.
Do you think the circumstances
are such that at least
the coverage will not drop
because despite the increase,
because of its size,
Pakistan is one of the top 10 countries
with zero dose children.
- Yeah.
- So there has been improvement,
but it's a large country like,
so other countries like Nigeria,
et cetera are also large.
So, do you think things will remain
at least stable if not improving in the,
like in these like this year 2022
where the data hasn't come out and 2023?
- So I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and perhaps this is
reflective of my nature
(laughs) and optimism,
but I think that it will not be a dip.
In fact, you may actually
see an improvement
because the whole vaccine
program got so much kudos,
so much recognition in the country
that I think that their
ability to understand
that they are able to provide vaccines
and and deploy vaccines
well is going to be higher.
I mentioned very good numbers
for the measles vaccine.
Again, third party evaluations,
et cetera will come in
and we'll figure out,
I think it'll not go down
and perhaps we'll improve,
but again, this is just my-
- Yeah.
- My view.
- So there are a couple of questions here,
this one, and then.
- [Audient] Thanks so much
for being with us today
and really insightful to think,
be able to look back and
consider the pandemic
and what happened in Pakistan.
And I have to say, as a always wonderful
to hear encouraging and you've given
us a kind of encouraging picture
of public health in Pakistan.
I think probably at the
back of all of our minds
is of course the flood and that impact.
So can you shift gears and
give us a little bit of a,
I don't know, look into the
crystal ball a little bit
and tell us what you imagine
or expect the public
health picture will be.
I'm specifically thinking of dengue now.
My entire family, Oliver
Punjab has dengue fever.
Is that kind of thing?
Could that be endemic or pandemic
or what do you imagine are the,
we kind of started the conversation
with the idea that there will
be more and more pandemics.
So what do you expect participate.
- So, my, the hat I now wear is fully
of an infectious diseases
physician working
in a cancer hospital.
(chuckles) So with that caveat,
I'll give you my view
because I cannot give
you an official view.
I do not have access to those numbers.
But let me tell you something interesting.
The same room, the
actual same physical room
and some of the same infrastructure
and people that were used for the NCOC
are being currently used
for the flood coordination.
I am told that it is
proving to be a harder job
because perhaps of the
nature of the problem,
but never there is the same kind of effort
is being put in longer term.
What will happen, I do not know.
But I think that at the present time, yes,
for vector bone diseases,
dengue in particular,
I, we keep worrying about malaria,
but what we've seen more perhaps
for whatever set of reasons is dengue.
That's one.
The other thing that I do worry about
is the kind of question
that was asked earlier.
So in the really flooded areas,
because road networks gets
disrupted, get disrupted,
the nearest health facility
that you're used to going to may not be
that easily accessible and something,
the other on side of the road is closer
or more practical right now.
And people are not used to
switching care this way,
especially when you're poor
and have less mobility.
Those are the things
that I do worry about.
I think that this is a space
that needs to be watched
and reviewed not just for
vaccine preventable diseases
or vector bone diseases,
but also for things which are,
which we consider routine. In other words,
antenatal care, nutrition,
just routine care
for illnesses that if not
taken care of in time go bad.
So that's kind of a very non-professional,
I apologize is kind of you,
but I'm being very careful with what I say
because I do not have an official role.
- Yeah.
So I guess this is the last
question from the audience
because we have to sort of wrap up.
- [Audient] Thanks for
joining us Dr. Sultan.
We've spoken a little bit
about marginalized communities
and difficult to access areas.
I wonder if you had,
if you could speak a little bit
to any specific challenges
you may have faced
in trying to access remote
northern border regions
like in Gil J Bal and Kashmir.
- So, just to set the context for,
the question was about
remote to access areas.
The parts of Pakistan especially
the ones that you highlighted
are mountainous areas
where especially during the winter months,
sometimes the access is blogged.
They are nomadic communities
that go out to meadows
for years, for months
at a time, et cetera.
And so that was the question.
How did you, some specific
issues from that part?
- Right?
So specifically let's
address Gil built down,
for example, as an example.
I think that we were surprised,
and I have to tell you this,
this was very much dependent
on the quality of the local leadership,
especially the bureaucratic leadership
that existed places
that had good chief min,
good chief secretaries of, and,
dynamic chief ministers
clearly made a difference.
And we, you could see that
it's almost in real time
deployment of vaccines,
provision of facilities,
making sure that the data was correct and,
real time and no gaps were happening.
So GB in particular, I can
tell you was exceptional.
We felt that they were able to,
and we focused on them be
for vaccine for example,
because GB is a popular.
- [Saad] Which is Gil
Pakistan same (indistinct).
- I'm sorry, I keep-
- [Saad] Yeah.
- Yeah, different countries.
So, Giled Stan is a
popular tourist destination
and so it was very important to ensure
that they indeed were protected.
So their uptake was not any worse
than the rest of the country.
And in many situations they
were way ahead of everyone else,
partly because they're,
the actual numbers,
the population is small,
but yes, the area is large.
Some of access issues are there.
We even had to, as an example,
switching gears from vaccine for example,
we realized that we could supply
the rest of the country relatively quickly
if there were shortages in
oxygen, for example, from,
so you have manufacturers
in south manufacturers
in the north and to move
trucks this way and that way,
but the northern areas are snow bound
in the winter.
And so it's hard to reach.
So the strategic reserves and,
large reservoirs of oxygen
were created in Gil Stan,
just specifically to make
sure that they don't get,
blocked out during those efforts.
So we did not see any
clear numerical differences
that would concern us.
One little, marginalized population women.
So when we started out,
there was a huge delta,
there was a fair amount
of gap between the uptake
between men and women as far
as vaccines were concerned.
And as time went on, we,
this is one metric we
tracked and as time went on,
it actually narrowed and we felt
that the most important way
to do this narrowing was to take
the vaccines to them instead of expecting
that they're gonna make the visit.
Men are more mobile,
they may be riding a motorcycle,
et cetera, going somewhere, reaching.
And, so it was important to address these.
So this was another number
that we felt was one to target,
one to narrow down.
I do not know the last number,
but I know that it was a
60 40 split in January,
so still there was a gap.
- So before we wrap up
a brief sort of question
and hopefully a quick answer
and you have been very comprehensive
and crisp in your answer so far as well.
So in that same spirit,
what are some of the things
you would do differently
or the country should
have done differently?
You know, lessons learned,
but specifically what some things are,
we learn lessons from them.
There are other things where the survey,
the control group, et cetera.
So what other things that
you would do differently?
- I think one is we should have handled
the initial lockdown a
little bit more differently.
I think I keep criticizing it
and I think that's one thing
I think the nuance could have put in,
been put in a little bit sooner,
but perhaps it was a bridge too far.
It was difficult to do.
That's one.
The other one that I think
we could have done differently
was the improved our
communication of the why.
Very often what we were saying,
we were doing this, okay,
we are shutting down schools
and then everybody said why.
And so the why probably had
to be enunciated better.
These would do the two things.
I think one in the realm of
data driven decision making,
fine tuning and better comms.
- Yeah.
So thank you very much.
And, I'll sort of
apologize to the audience.
I know that there are questions.
I know that sort of,
I switched off the vibrate
function of my phone
because I learned it the hard way earlier
because you know, a lot of the recordings
have this, that little.
- Buzz.
- Buzz, et cetera.
But I know I'm getting a
lot of texts with questions.
People are not texting me directly.
By the way,
we have someone actually sort
of transcribing questions
from Zoom to me and we as usual,
we are not able to
answer all the questions
or able to put together
put all the questions
in front of our guest.
But thank you and thank
you for the specific
and candid conversation
around the pandemic response.
And for the rest of you,
we'll continue this series,
the conversation series with
a lot of exciting guests
that will be coming to Yale.
Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
- Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
(soft music)